three European politicians they speak
different languages but they're all
singing the same tune double my rental
and Europe equipped alamogordo Catalonia
sakakibara Yamuna poverty Baltar la
Cuesta Appa and that's weird because one
belief that unites these nationalist
populist European leaders is that the
European Union should be less United
since the euro crisis of 2009 and the
migrant crisis of 2015 these right-wing
populist movements have grown in
strength and a number l-dopa host
invites your table these HTV Leo in
tulip Miguel will Papa Joffre Kabul his
campaign against Muslim refugees won his
party two-thirds of the seats in
Hungary's general election in 2018
Poland's ruling Law and Justice Party
doesn't sound all that different Soichi
jmf ante jnanavan Torah - Provident
Sharia law and justice won an outright
majority in 2015
every European country has its own
version Tomio Okamura is a Czech
nationalist politician born in Japan who
wants a zero-tolerance policy on
immigration nation' acidophilus
sabotages a meeow meeow Dante is named
after ski and make impossible equal to
it's not clear what this means but it
plays into European fears of what they
call an invasion in other words
immigration I would stop immigration of
non-western immigrants immediately they
all accuse Brussels
of behaving like a dictatorship
my proton we talk abou salut for such as
mr. chilly ago police ammo staff knows
the key to Azeroth
which is ironic given that they're all
running in democratic elections for the
EU Parliament they often speak of a
supposed plot by mainstream leaders like
Angela Merkel to replace Europeans of
lower-paid migrants so no convento Kelly
McGraw CEO nation projeto to be ATO -
auntie Otto / faucet we're a ethnic
Amenti poeple Europe a Canova Schiavi
topic area trailer allure apparel or
lavoro and they tend not to like
feminism or gay rights they may say some
provocative or even hateful things but
their language and ideas are consistent
all across Europe and they are clearly
effective pollsters predict that these
Euroskeptic parties will see a
significant rise in votes in the
European election ironically it's the
euro skeptic parties that seem to be
doing the best job building pan European
politics the question is whether the
parties that believe in a stronger
Europe can do the same thing
[Music]